teame
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
今日は国としきっかけ好き嫌い先生定職について話をする
中級以上の人ならわかると思うがある程度日本語が上達すると
日本語上手っていう言葉が嫌になってくるもう褒められたくないからではない
外国人特にアメリカ人を褒められて育つ生物である
理由1日本語超ズっていう言葉を単品で注文できないからだ
日本語上手も一のセットでくる僕はこのセットを国としきっかけ好き嫌い先生定食と
呼んでいる
例を見てみよう友達誰日本語上手
ありがとうございます桃源デスクにはどちらですか
アメリカですメイク
赤どのぐらい勉強してるんですか日本の7年間
なんで日本に来ようと思いましたアニメとか日本の音楽が好きで納豆食べられますか
あぁ好きです英語の先生とかやってるんですかいや実は大学で働いてます友達だ
日本語上手ありがとうございます桃源デスクにはどちらですか
大体こんな感じです
場合によってキャノリーブスに似ていると言われませんか
とか言え20がありますかとかも聞かれたりする
日本人にはもちろん丸気はないっていうのは国と式かけ好き嫌い先生定食には食材が一
つしかない
好奇心日本人がアメリカに行くと同じ目に遭う毎日寿司を食べて飽きませんか
とかきゃりーぱみゅぱみゅ見た事がありますかとか好奇心
しかしやはり食材が少ない為邦敏きっかけ好き嫌い先生停職4回以上を食べると飽きて
くるのも確かなことだ
アメリカ人は普通食材が少ないが多くの向けだと言う
ことで今日皆さんに国俊きっかけ好き嫌い先生定食を防ぐための実をいくつか紹介し
たいとぜひ活用してください
日本語上手アメリカ人7年間シーナリーの納豆兄ケビンコースの親戚じゃありませんし
この先生も行っていません
tan
日本語上手やすいばクリントンについてと思います
日本語上手スウェイバーなんで緑なのに日本人は信号は桜と言います
日本語上手そういえばガイ先生はほぼまだを殺せたのになんで86ペンには使わなかっ
た理由
日本語上手あ日本語すごく上手ですね
はいやっとても上手です手水
よく
日本語とても上手です
ミョンアールヌーボーずぅー do our revolution とっ
er ん
日本語上手今何と言いました
いやその日本語どうぞもう1回言ってください
日本語上手白人だから日本生まれ育ちは考えられない
そういうことか安いませんそのそう思ってるんでしょ
a あのそういうことではなくすごく隆著に話されていましたネタ等勧めハート本だけ
という可能
日本語上手
日本人です
日本語上手国はどちらですか
納豆食べられますか日本語上手国はどちらですか
納豆を食べられますか3 dq 7曲なんだ
me
nande nande